back to your three buckets
of inflation so the first bucket we were
talking about which was the federal
reserve board's kind of
transitory transient kind of thing i
believe investors
when they hear adjectives they put
numbers to it
so if a business the corporate
management team were to say in a
conference call our business is up
slightly right
you kind of say it's up one two percent
and they say modestly up three four if
they say moderately mid-single digits
that they significantly are probably
getting double digits
right they don't say that but we
attribute
numbers to those words so when you hear
the words transitory
i think for most investors the thing is
several months yeah and it goes away
and and part of that is the pandemic
related base effects
start to moderate right so your year
over year jumps and inflation will start
to slow
theoretically that starts in june right
with the june day
because i'm saying that's which means
you get in july right so
it's several months and then it
dissipates the problem is that some of
the issues that we're talking about
in terms of you mentioned ships before
so those chip shortages
um the the idea of of
um of labor costs so if you look at the
national federation of the defendant
business their biggest problem
is quality of labor they don't have the
right fits for the people it's not
you know there's this whole discussion
around is it the enhanced unemployment
checks even feel our work i'm sure
there's some people
doing that but not generally um there's
some people who are fearful of coving
and going back and getting sick there's
an answer there called get vaccinated
but
whatever right yeah um and there's a
third one
which is women who can't get their kids
back to school
and that's a huge number and you know in
that sense
they want schools open so they can get
back to work it's not they don't want to
come back to work but again that might
have been a cashier at a store that's no
longer reopening
and they don't have the skill set to do
operate a machine
shop you know working at lathe in the
machine shop in waterloo iowa or work
in coding in silicon valley or drive a
truck
you know with a big with a big rig um
they may
you know they can't they cannot work on
a construction site
you really want people who are untrained
to be you know an infrastructure site
with a jackhammer
probably take their foot off so you know
they're
we have skills mismatches too and we've
had a skills
mitch match mismatch for a long time
but i feel like the changes yeah
and now we have countless brick and
mortar
employees with retail sales experience
and that's about it
look it's not if some of the retail
sales experience can go to work in a
hotel pretty easily and you know stand
behind a desk and say can i check you in
right mr mrs i mean you don't need to be
a skilled
again operator of the machine tool to do
you know there's a different kind of
skill set you know it's like yeah
welding is one of
is a really high-end skill set welders
make a lot of money
i know and yeah you wouldn't want to
give me one of those torches and
yeah right actually body part off my old
boss richard fisher that was his
favorite example welders it's really
underwater welders the guys who fix
pipelines off the gulf coast
they make these so these are navy
frogmen former navy frogmen who learn at
a weld
and they get paid you know six figures
wow
usually starting with a three or four
because it's really dangerous to go
after a hurricane under there
and try to reconnect those those cash
lines um i know where i'm going to send
my kids
it's it's it's i mean i i shouldn't i'm
going to say because i
often say things i shouldn't say but i
used to tell my son as a doctor in
psychology that he shouldn't become a
plumber and my wife says why why did you
don't do that
and i said because i think he'll make
more money cleaning crap out of people's
toilets than other brains
[Laughter]
and but they say that as a joke but i'm
not
actually joking no i mean if you think
about the average age of an electrician
in this country or
i mean when i was in high school i mean
there were the guys in shop there was
shop
to try and find shopping in a high
school today no they're probably doing
programming somewhere
coding but which is fine there's nothing
wrong with that but we don't have
mechanics we don't have
uh electricians we don't have plumbers
and you know you try getting a
contractor to show up
when they say they're going to show up
at your home so
these are you know these are really good
jobs get paid really well but we have a
lot of people don't have those skills
so the skill set issue is a real problem
and we're going to spend money on
training we're going to have to
to get people there but that doesn't get
resolved overnight no you know that's
a generation i'm saying we can't remedy
some of the issues so i was talking
about the nfib data
um historically when the nfib is telling
us small business people are telling us
that quality of labor is a big problem
within six to twelve months you have
significant wage increases
so i'm hearing it now i was talking to
somebody recently
the family office that they own a bunch
of hotels and
they need to fill 200 jobs and offering
thousand dollar signing bonuses and only
three people signed
yeah right um you know they're they're
they're people trying to find
how home builders are trying to find
people who work on their you know on
their
sites to put up new homes because we
have a severe shortage of them
yep you don't have the people they're
not available so i think these are
issues that aren't transitory they could
stick around for
nine to twelve months if you need copper
it'll take three years to put up a new
copper mine
so these supply issues don't get
resolved as quickly and that's why i
call them sticky
now you might sit there in nine months
and say you know we're going to replace
copper with
plastic or aluminum or something like
that in that
in that specific application yeah you
might say i'm going to bring on some
robots if i don't have enough people
but again this is not something business
can do literally overnight
yeah i was actually i read a headline
that a major manufacturer
was closing a plant and moving it to
mexico
that was the first time i'd seen one of
those headlines in a long time
um having been an industrial analyst
years ago
the quality of labor and product out of
mexico has not been as good as the ball
they would always have to bring it back
and redo it
um and so we'll see look there are a
number of great machiadoras that that
probably do fantastic work
but i i just remember that my experience
was kicking out and saying ooh that
didn't work out so well last time
so wage inflation that's that's that's a
big boogie man
it's 60 percent of corporate cost yeah
that's what we have to remember if
you're if your transportation costs went
up
deliver something and maybe it was cost
you three percent more it's one thing
but it's 60
of your costs going up you need to do
something about it so either we're going
to get some
pressure to raise prices
and the other one would be if you don't
if you're not able to do so then you're
getting emergent corporate profit margin
pressure
well there's the issue of pricing power
right yep so some bumblebees have them
some families don't and the ones that
don't are going to have to
be really really creative or their
margins will suffer so
it's kind of a tug of work are you get
some inflation where are you going to
get some
margin margins marginal pressure right
it's one of the two
there's not kind of this easy narrow
path in between
and you know i i'm very happy to not
work for the fed because i think
navigating this path is going to be very
difficult
everybody loves you when you're adding
you know boost to the punch bowl they
don't like you when you take away the
punch ball
no i mean just just the the very idea i
mean one
one cpi print and you know we all lost
our minds uh
and people were worried about the cbi
print you know they were they knew that
it was going to be bad and it still
shook them what if it's shaking them in
august and september
and that's a whole different issue
i think the the bond market may test the
fed kind of like they did in february
and march
if there's again i'm not talking about
regime change but i am talking about a
little bit more persistent
stickier inflation than transitory
transient
so what so what can the fed do
i mean housing is a i mean how housing
is an issue right now
look the feds have been boxed in i think
is the best way and people have said
that
they put themselves in a kind of an
uncomfortable situation
and now they have to kind of i don't
know very let's hope and pray because
it's too strong to term but
um but they better be right or they're
gonna get egg on their face and they go
on the
central bank space the most important
central bank of the world isn't the best
for us no and it's it's interesting to
me
that um that the whole financial
stability
issue has come to the forefront in fed
speaks
so quickly and now the ecv is kind of
echoing the same it's
which is which is actually i'll give him
credit for that for even bringing it up
will brenner brought it up in the in the
report but
it's usually too late though i
understand that but they
tried to avoid all of that 99 99
they just didn't talk about it you know
you had the original irrational
exuberance
right that was 96 right it was way way
ahead of its time yep and then that was
it
and then and then took off no i'm saying
but then when you got to
99.com frenzy
nary a word for the fed on this so i
gave them a little bit of credit at
least they want to they want to be on
the right side of it in case
something bad happens we talked about it
if you paid attention or not is your
issue but we at least mentioned it
um they're not going to mention a lot
but they'll at least get some credit for
that
but it's also interesting to see you
know you know um
i'll say chair chair yellen um treasury
secretary ellen almost
make a chair statement oh that was and
then pull it back a bit
and then you saw the fed said you know
in the minutes
the commentary around if things gets is
stronger than we would have to
react in the interest rate environment
and it's like you know big
big duh like of course that's part of
your mandate
so but it was interesting that they're
willing to even have that show up in
print
yeah like they're aware that this is a
potential problem even if they don't
think it's going to be a problem
well and they're starting to talk about
housing a little bit more
so you can almost you can almost imagine
that
i mean people people don't realize that
it's 40 billion dollars a month of
mortgage-backed securities
but prepayments have been insane
so you might have months when the fed is
buying three times that amount
in the mortgage-backed securities market
just to reinvest just to keep the stock
of mortgages uh where they are and it's
it's just a huge
influence right now and yeah
people talk about the feds manipulating
the markets right i've heard that
comment and
that's their job they're allowed you
know if things get stuck
in you know in the markets the fed comes
in with a crowbar
it kind of gets it's unstuck that's
that's part of their job again if you
and i do we go to jail
but um i don't really have a problem
with that i think that is their
their charge i think the the debate
is have they gone too far
[Music]